Why Do We Toast Drinks?
Humans throughout history have made a habit
of basing a great deal of our traditions and
customs around food.
The curious practice of raising our drink
containers is one of the most ancient of these.
To answer your question, for starters, we’ll
dispel a myth.
You may have heard that the tradition of toasting
originated out of a fear of poisoning- the
idea being that clinking two glasses together
would cause the liquid from both to spill
into one another; thus, the people you’re
drinking with wouldn’t poison you as they’d
then be poisoning themselves.
As interesting as this historical rumour is,
not surprisingly, there is not a single shred
of evidence backing up this conjecture.
As to the real origin, because the practice
of honouring through a drink offering seems
to have begun in pre-history, it’s hard
to say who first got the idea.
In fact, most ancient societies show evidence
of doing this.
The Ancient Greeks would offer libations to
the Gods as a ritualistic practice, as well
as make a point of drinking to each other’s
health.
Evidence of this can be found in The Odyssey
when Ulysses drinks to the health of Achilles.
The Romans placed such an importance on drinking
to health that at one point in time the Senate
passed a decree that stated that all must
drink to Emperor Augustus at every meal.
The Decline and Fall of the Roman Empire even
describes a feast where Attila the Hun indulges
in at least three toasts for every course.
The term “toast” itself originated in
the 16th century.
One of the first written accounts of it was
in Shakespeare’s The Merry Wives of Windsor
when the character of Falstaff demands - “Go
fetch me a quart of sack; put a toast in’t.”
To translate, he’s asking for a great deal
of wine with a piece of (literal) toast in
it.
I can hear your disgusted outrage and objections
to adding toast to wine, but it was actually
quite a common practice at the time.
This is thought to be due to the quality of
wine in the past- it was in many cases inferior
to our modern vintages.
Thus, placing a piece of toast within a jug
was supposed to soak up some of the acidity
and improve the flavour.
This also had the side benefit of giving people
something to do with a piece of stale bread,
often spiced or with fruit embedded, that
would improve the bread’s palatability.
Up until very recently in history, wasting
food just wasn’t something people tended
to do, so finding ways to make stale bread
taste good was fairly common- waste not, want
not.
(This was also more or less how French Toast
got its start.)
Over the coming centuries, the term “toasting”,
in English, slowly transformed to incorporate
traditional libations and the honouring of
people.
In the early days of this connection, the
person being honoured often received the physical
toast saturated with wine at the end.
Toasting became so popular in the 17th and
18th centuries that Toastmasters came into
being.
Acting as a kind of party referee, they were
there to ensure that the toasting didn’t
become too excessive and that everyone got
their fair share of toasting opportunities.
This may sound silly, but it was a desperately
needed role.
If left to their own devices, guests would
occasionally go on toasting every individual
in the room.
(This being a great excuse to drink excessive
amounts of alcohol without seeming like a
lush.)
Elaborate drinking games soon became interwoven
with the toasting ritual, and most of them
seem to have been designed to impress the
ladies.
One of the more “charming” examples of
this involves a gentleman cutting himself,
mixing the blood with his drink and then toasting
to his lady of choice in order to prove his
devotion.
Shakespeare is once again our authority when
it comes to this particular early, bizarre
toasting practice.
In The Merchant of Venice the King of Morocco
talks of stabbing himself and then laments
-
“I stabbed my arm to drink her health,
The more fool I, the more fool I.”
Another odd custom of the time involved toasting
to a lady’s beauty by drinking from her
shoe…
Unsurprisingly, the sheer excess of these
practices, and drunkenness that often ensued,
lead to anti-toasting clubs and movements.
Although they were unsuccessful, the eventual
result was toasting becoming more of a civilized,
restrained and intellectual pursuit, rather
than one purely designed for imbibing alcohol.
There were even “Toastmaster” books published
around this time.
One of these was The Toastmasters Guide by
T Hughes, which strove to instill proper toasting
etiquette within the reader.
Some of these books include examples of short,
appropriate, but also witty toasts that were
relevant to all occasions.
Examples of these include -
“Mirth, wine and love.
May the works of our nights never fear the
day-light.
Old wine and young women.
Prudence and temperance with claret and champagne.
Love without fear, and life without care.
May we never want a friend to cheer us, or
a bottle to cheer him.
A generous heart and a miser’s fortune”
Evidence of this change in etiquette is still
apparent today, and there are even still Toastmaster
Clubs.
Furthermore, while we still often include
alcohol in our toasting, drinking directly
after a toast is usually far more restrained,
often just a sip, and more reminiscent of
its roots – a practice used to honour someone
in a respectful and revered manner, rather
than a great excuse to get drunk.
As for the aforementioned raising of the drinking
vessels and clinking them together, there
are a couple of theories surrounding the origin
of this, but as with the ultimate origin of
toasting, we can only guess.
Probably the most popular, and simplest, theory
is that people originally did this to raise
their drink to the gods or person being honoured
in offering, before taking a drink themselves.
As to the clinking, this perhaps has similar
origins of symbolically offering your drink
to the people around you in a general toast.
Bonus Fact:
• A word that tends to go hand in hand with
toasting, “cheers”, or in Medieval times
“cheres”, derived from the Anglo-French
word for ‘the face’.
If we go a little further back, in Old French
the word “chiere” meant “face, countenance,
look, expression.”
By the late 14th century “cheres” had
evolved to “cheere” and came to mean a
mood that was reflected in the face.
By the 18th century, it had come to mean gladness
and it began being used to show support and
encouragement.
Considering that wine, or alcohol in general,
is something we drink in both celebration
and lamentation, it’s hardly surprising
that “cheers” eventually became a part
of the toasting ritual.